MALE SPEAK: So good afternoon,
everyone.
Today we have another
outstanding
Authors at Google Talk.
We're very honored to welcome
Bryant Austin
to our midst today.
He is a conservationist, a
photographer first and
foremost, and really a
storyteller of the whales that
are throughout the world.
He has over the past decade or
more embarked on a quest to
create large format photography
of the world's whales.
And his story is extremely
fascinating, both from a
technical standpoint and for how
he is able to change the
conversation of whale
conservation away from just
the whales jumping out of the
water, like the Pacific life
visual to something even more
compelling more direct, which
is these face to face
interactions with whales, and
the look in their eyes,
so to speak.
So we'll invite him on stage,
and we'll also have time for
some questions at the end.
So please join me in welcoming
Bryant to Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRYANT AUSTIN: Thank
you, Cliff.
This is my first time here.
It's pretty exciting, so
thanks for having me.
Oh, is this--
so I thought what I would do
is just give you a little
perspective on kind of
what led to this.
I mentioned I make very big
photographs of whales.
These are life size photographs,
but also very
high resolution.
And it's not anything that
happened overnight.
It's been an evolution, so I
look forward to sharing that
with you today.
For the past 10 years with
whales, I've wanted to create
something that would move and
inspire someone who has no
interest in whales.
Someone who may eat whales.
And I wanted to see if that
might be possible.
And so I started this probably
in 1998, actually.
And I'd been an artist since
I was five, a painter.
Switched to photography in my
'20s, and swam with my first
whale in 1994.
And took pictures, and looked at
them, and they just did not
convey what I experienced
with the whale.
And in fact, none of the
photographs I've seen of
whales underwater convey what
one experiences when they're
so close to you.
So I gave up photography 20
years ago, photographing
whales and volunteering
with many conservation
organizations.
And really became burned out
from that experience.
And I was burned out from
painting, and so I decided in
1998 to begin photographing
marine mammals as an art form
with no real agenda.
I just wanted to see if I
could create something
special, and really what was
at the core of the work is
this idea of decoupling the
pressure of making a living
from photography, from
the craft itself.
So I started with sea otters,
and by the time I was done
with sea otters, I started
with whales.
A professor loaned me his Zodiac
from UC Santa Cruz, and
I just started to get the
courage and the interest to go
further offshore.
And this was 2003, so I had a
boat, a team of volunteers.
That was a trailer I lived in
for four years near the Long
Marine Lab.
Everything I earned went
into this work.
Experimenting with all kinds
of camera equipment.
This is a gyro stabilized steady
cam that I built with
the first autofocused medium
format camera made by
Hasselblad.
And I would wait for the most
ideal weather conditions.
It only happened a couple times
a month, when winds were
less than five knots and the
sea states were calm.
We would go out and cover
up to 80 miles a day
in search of whales.
And during the four years of
doing this, this was, I think,
one of the only photographs
I had.
It's just this idea of bringing
together like, sea
states, atmospheric conditions
and behavior.
Bringing it all together, and
that was one of the few
photographs.
And I was really starting
to doubt my pursuits.
I wasn't sure if this
was something
that was a good idea.
And towards the end of this
time, I had an encounter with
a blue whale.
And with whales, I didn't know
how to photograph them
underwater in a way
that would inspire
unexplored thought and emotion.
And above water I had some
ideas, but I'd never motor up
to a whale.
I'd never swim after a
whale or pursue them.
And now I wait for them
to come to me.
But at the time, I didn't
even know that.
I just thought, well,
I'm here.
I really don't know what to do,
other than position myself
where the light is best.
And whenever we'd see a blue
well or a humpback, the boat
would drop down to two miles
an hour, steady course, no
changes, and observe.
And they're foraging
300 feet down.
They're coming up, and one day
a blue whale surfaced right
next to the boat.
Like, six feet.
It was right here.
His head was bigger
than my boat.
My boat was 20 feet long,
and there was his head.
And this nostril, the blue
whales have a splashguard that
looks a lot like our nose.
And it just came out of
water, and a 30 foot
blow went right up.
And then you could hear this
sucking sound, this cavernous
sucking sound, suggesting
this great mass
underneath the water.
I mean, it was incredible.
Four times the size
of our boat, and
my legs were shaking.
I was forgetting to breathe as
I'm composing photographs of
this blue silverback rolling
in front of me.
Through the viewfinder
I could see a rainbow
casting this blow.
I could see my own shadow in the
blow with the whale's body
right there.
And I thought, this is it.
After three years of effort,
I've got something.
This is what I've been waiting
for, and this was the photo
that came back.
That's actually what
it looked like.
And it was the only time the
film came back unexposed.
And I had decided,
I've got to quit.
I started to go down
the rabbit hole.
I don't have what it takes to
keep exploring this, both
emotionally and financially.
And around the same time, I had
already booked a trip to
the South Pacific to reacquaint
myself with the
underwater world of whales.
And this was with
humpback whales.
And I didn't want to go.
I couldn't refund it.
So I was there.
The whole time I'm there, I'm
trying to figure out how to
rebuild my life when I get back
home and stop all this.
And this a really horrible
photo, and it just shows you
how difficult it is.
But it just really, it was in
my third week in the South
Pacific, and it really just
summed it up for me.
What's not really being
convinced in this photo, it's
150 foot visibility.
That water is over 60 feet
deep, and you can see the
boulders and all the features
on the bottom.
You can see their shadow
And I thought, this
is incredible.
It's like I was almost standing
on the edge and
looking out into the abyss
of what I was pursuing.
I realized to really explore
this, you need
to do it full time.
And you need to be with these
whale for entire seasons, up
to three months to see the full
spectrum of behavior.
And also, the person left our
group and is swimming after
the whale, trying to get
photographs, and compromising
the encounter.
The whales are swimming away.
And that's very symbolic
to me.
It's this mentality
of scarcity.
And we impose it on ourselves.
We say, well, I'm only with the
whales for two weeks, or
three weeks, so I must chase
them, pursue them.
I've got to get the shot to
either make this a viable
business of impress
my friends.
And it's like, it's
no, no, no.
You've got to decouple from
that and just really be
willing to work on whale time.
And so that realization, to
me, like, OK, this is it.
This is like, I'm looking
out at the abyss.
It's like, do I want to
keep going forward?
How do I be present for three
months with this?
How do I do that?
I didn't know how, nor was
I inspired to do it.
And I still wanted to quit, and
it was an experience that
moved me to tears.
I was like, OK, I'm giving up
on this, and I'm going to
rebuild my life.
And by the end of the day, that
same day, I was with this
mother and calf.
And they were about to do
something that would shine a
light on what I could offer,
what I could create.
And it started with
this whale here.
This little calf on the bottom
is swimming up to me.
And they both kind of churned
and came right up to me, and
the calf came up to me on
a collision course.
He was just right at me.
And at the last moment he turned
away, and I was using a
fish eye lens, which
is traditional.
I don't use them anymore.
They're great for small books
and calendars, and things,
where it encouples the whole
whale's body in one photo.
And that's what I was doing.
That's what I was taught.
And I knew he was close.
And the fish eye makes him look
far away, and I thought,
I'd better lower this camera.
He's going to hit my camera
with his tail.
And I lowered the camera,
and this was the
last photo I took.
And I remember being immediately
just taken aback
by the sight of a
belly button.
Literally just beyond arm's
reach, going by me.
And seeing all of their
true colors, and the
fine, subtle details.
And I remember appreciated his
body, his musculature and
blubber, and skin just moving
and flexing as he was powering
down one more time.
And he powered down.
And that fluke went right
by my face like this.
And I was just in awe.
I mean, this was a five week old
calf who has that kind of
mind body awareness in
relationship to me, which, why
should he be concerned
about me?
It was really humbling.
And I was sitting there trying
to process the moment, trying
to see if there was something
to this that I could pursue.
And another moment passed, and
then I felt a single, just
solid tap on my shoulder.
And it was too solid of a tap to
be human, and I felt dread
as I turned to look.
And it was the mother, and she
had extended her 15 foot long
pectoral fin that weighs two
tons, and she touched me with
the very tip of it.
And the camera was to my side,
and I was eye to eye with her.
She was looking into my eyes.
And I immediately saw
what was missing.
What I could offer.
Moments like this, on their
terms, and on their scale.
She had this expression, it was
a very calm, heavy lidded,
mindful gaze.
And it's very penetrating.
And it was a moment where the
word whale just fails.
It's a meaningless word, and
there's something else there.
And that was it.
I had the inspiration, and it
took another year and a half
to find the courage
to pursue it.
And here was the idea.
If you could see this little
black dot, that's a very
generous representation
of a digital sensor
on the biggest camera.
And the idea of putting all
this information on one
sensor, on a 45 foot
whale just seemed--
it wasn't going to work.
And I thought at best, you could
focus on this area and
make a portrait, which is
one of the things I do.
And I was really interested in
seeing what happens if I turn
the camera on its side
and just do a mosaic.
And that's what I began.
That's that direction I went
and explored, and I hadn't
quit my job yet.
I was trying to live
in both worlds.
I was trying to do this
and keep my day job.
And this was a photo from
my first season.
I sold my truck and all the
camera gear I didn't need.
I raised enough money for five
weeks, and to begin exploring
this process and learning.
And I came back with nothing.
I mean, this was one of the
photos I created, but none
were life size.
And I learned a lot, and I was
really starting to feel sad
about trying to keep both
things going, and the
depression was really
powerful.
And I remember being at my
therapist's office, and she
told me something that you
never want to hear your
therapist say.
She just looked at me one
day, just said, I don't
know how to help you.
And this was a time where I
was on the brink of being
checked into a crisis center.
And I just looked up
at her, it just me.
I remembered that feeling I
had when I had the first
inspiration.
I need to leave all this
safe and familiar.
I need to pursue this.
And I told her, I need
to quit my job.
And then just everything
just drained.
I felt fine.
And that was seven years ago.
And so off I went.
I sold everything I owned.
I quit my job at a sea
otter research lab.
I raised enough funding for 124
days of field work, and
this would allow me to learn and
explore all the different
possibilities, to recreate that
sensation I experienced
two years earlier.
This is a mother calf pair.
This is one of the whales I
would see regularly, and this
is him as well.
His name is Beethoven.
We gave them him name because he
would swim down to his mom
and his back on his mom's body,
and wave his pectoral
fins like a conductor.
This was my one and only
attempt to make a
composite at that time.
The whale on the right swam
up to my friend here, and
immediately did a 180 and
came right back at me.
And I took some photos.
Let's see if this works.
So those are some of
the photos I took.
And you have to remember, I'm
six feet away from this whale.
This is a small whale.
Probably 27 feet long.
Probably only like
two years old.
Pectoral fins are right here.
I'm so close that the pectoral
fin is going underneath my
body just by about this much.
And all I see is this wall of
whale, and he's probably about
this tall, which a small
for a humpback.
And your entire field of view is
enveloped by this body, and
then you see this
eye approaching.
I'm looking through the
viewfinder here, and here I'm
watching him.
And this eye's looking around,
and looking at me.
And sadly, what I learned from
this experience was the sun
was in the right position.
It wasn't behind my head.
And what I've taken away from
that experience is always keep
the sun at your back.
And that means if a whale comes
up to inspect my feet,
even if it's six feet away,
I don't turn to face him.
I keep my back to him.
And it requires a
lot of trust.
And my feeling is that
our eyes gravitate
towards each other.
And so I just hold the
direction I want, and
hopefully they'll come around.
And they do occasionally, will
come right up and look at me.
They don't like to look in the
sun either, because their eyes
are very sensitive to light,
but it's the only way these
photographs can be made.
They don't like strobes.
And this is Beethoven again.
The inspiration was
really powerful.
It was to the point I
couldn't ignore it.
So I'm doing my best to just
follow it, and every step of
the way when you make all these
big decision,s you quit
your job, you sell everything
you own.
And you're like, well,
how do I feel?
And it's like, no, I
still feel good.
This is the right thing.
And there's no other choice,
and I keep going.
But by the end of those 124
days, I had nothing, and I was
still learning.
And I was looking at the
prospect of coming home with
nothing, and for the first
time in two years, I was
thinking, I'm going to have to
quit and rebuild my life.
This is insanity.
I'm just going so far down
the rabbit hole now
that I have to quit.
And I had a sleepless night, I
had just a few weeks left, and
I remember, I didn't
sleep at all.
And just filled with anxiety,
and just a lot of regret.
And we went back out to sea
that morning, and within a
half hour, I reunited with
Beethoven and his mom.
And his mom was about 60 feet
down, and Beethoven was doing
the same old thing.
Rubbing his back on her.
And mom started to come up to
surface to have a look.
And she got really close, and
Beethoven swam off, and then I
lost track of him.
And I thought, uh-oh,
where'd he go?
And mom was 12 feet down, and
she just rolled up and looked
at me, and her eye went wide,
and I knew something was up.
And then my body just
moved forward at the
surface like this.
I'm on snorkel.
And I felt this pressure against
my back and my head,
and I strained to look up, and I
saw the underside of a whale
go over the top of my head
and stop right here.
And I lowered my camera, and its
pec fin came around, and
just went right against my chest
and pressed me to his
belly, and we stayed
there together and
breathed at the surface.
And I didn't want to startle
him, so I just stayed there.
And my assistant was in the
water, and she grabbed my arm
and just separated us gently,
and we went back in the boat.
I've had strange events where
I've wanted to quit, and then
something like that happens.
It's happened several times.
And the very next day, I
composed what would be my only
life sized portrait of a
whale during that time.
And this is another calf,
a five week old
calf we named Mozart.
And when you learn something,
you're learning, you're
developing, you're making
a lot of mistakes.
When you're 6,000 miles from
home, it's hard to just say,
well, I need this
kind of lens.
I need a more portrait lens.
You can't just go online and
get one from B&H Photos.
So you're kind of committed to
the mistakes you've made with
the lens choices, and
I realized the lens
I had was too wide.
I really needed something
narrow, because the more
narrow the field of view, the
more pixels per feature.
And that's really important
when you want
to capture the eye.
And this, well, and his mom swam
around me for 20 minutes.
Mozart had his pec fin out like
this, and mom's dorsal
fin was like this.
So he's hitching a ride.
They're just cruising around,
going around me, coming closer
and closer.
Finally they were underneath me,
about 15 feet, and Mozart
just went like this and
separated from his mom, and
came right up to see me.
He was less than three feet
from my camera when I took
this picture.
And it's like he overcame all
my mistakes, and I took this
picture, and that was it.
This was my last photograph
from the season.
It's just me saying goodbye on
my last day before I flew back
to the States.
And really, that portrait of
Mozart was my only currency.
To print the amount of work,
I had to sell my underwater
camera here and fully
commit to this.
And started my first show eight
months later, and really
just began the process of
putting the work out there.
And during that time, it
was a two year time
between field seasons.
And I thought about
this whale a lot.
This is Mozart's mother, and
this is probably 10 feet away.
And I thought, hey,
look at this.
This is great.
I can make a life size portrait
of an adult whale.
And when I zoomed it up,
enlarged it, the
eye just fell apart.
It was just blobs of color.
And I realized I would have
to be closer than 10 feet.
And that concerned me more than
fund raising or getting
commissions than
anything else.
And it took years to
overcome that.
And it wasn't until 2008, I was
invited to exhibit my work
at the International Whaling
Commission meeting in
Santiago, Chile.
And this is the security
detail there.
It's a very highly politicized,
polarized event.
Can be pretty compelling and
dramatic with the opposition.
And instead of being outside
with the signs, I was able to
come inside with the work.
And we had an exhibition in
the lobby where all the
delegates walked by every day
to the conference venue.
Even invited, asked if we could
include the portrait
outside the conference room
where they have coffee.
And they said, it was with no
text, and they said it would
be too controversial to have a
portrait of a healthy whale
just there.
So that actually gave me hope.
This was a photo of the actual
exhibit in the lobby.
Had a reception.
It was really an incredible
time.
My last couple of days there
I met this gentleman, Peter
Hall, who's the CEO of Hunter
Hall Ethical Managed Funds,
who ultimately commissioned me
to create my largest work.
And it would be the largest work
I could create that would
be shown in Norway and Japan
for the first time.
And so in 2009, I started
this process with him.
And it's really simple.
It's what would happen with
a 50 megapixel camera, a
portrait lens, like a
50 or 80 millimeter,
so it's very narrow.
And from six or five feet
away from a whale's eye?
What would that look like?
And it's really exciting, but
it's never happened before.
it's never been done.
And I just was really curious
to see what would happen.
So Peter was able to make that
possible, and right after New
Year's Day, as soon as the
camera arrived, it was one of
the first batch of cameras that
were sent out, I went to
the eastern Caribbean to
work with sperm whales.
And I was actually in search of
a specific family known as
the Group of Seven, and in that
family there is one whale
who is known to tolerate people
in the water, and who
might even come close.
And Peter able to fund five
weeks of field work, which is
a terribly short amount of
time, but I was grateful.
And I thought, if I only have
five, weeks I need to find a
whale that may allow me to
create, finally create a full
body composite of
a whale's body.
And I spent five weeks there,
like I said, and I never found
the Group of Seven.
And I was looking at coming home
with nothing once again.
And I went out, my last
full day, and I saw--
during this whole time,
I never found
the Group of Seven.
This was another whale, and I
saw this whale over and over.
And it seemed like he was
tolerating me more and more
every time we were
in the water.
When I'm in the water,
I snorkel.
I'm motionless.
I don't swim after them,
I just observe.
And I want to allow them to
explore any natural curiosity
they may have of me.
And this is what might encourage
a very close
inspection, which is really
critical to making these
photographs.
And this whale never came close
enough, but on my last
encounter, he was about
eight feet away.
And we just kind of
swam together like
this, side by side.
And I would compose pictures,
and he opened his jaw, which
normally is a threat display,
but he shot out a squid
tentacle at me.
It was about this big, and
about that big around.
And I regretted not taking it,
because I thought maybe it was
stuck between his teeth,
but it was too big.
And it just started to open
my eyes about how you can
communicate intention with a
whale, just by showing up
every day for three months, or
five weeks, whatever you can
do, being respectful and
consistent, and just being in
their presence.
And giving them the
space to explore
their own natural curiosity.
So to have that consistency,
visually, everything
I wear is the same.
Same boat, for the acoustics,
to make sure they can become
familiar with that.
And that's what really
inspired that.
And as I was saying earlier,
on my last day of the five
weeks, I met this whale.
He's a two and a half year old
calf, and his mom swam by very
closely to me.
Not close enough, again, but
she kind of moved her tail
like this by me.
And I was like, whoa, and I took
a picture of her tell.
And I was going home
within days, and I
thought, OK, great.
I have a life size photo of a
tail, or part of a tail, and
we'll just make it big and share
it anyway, and just see
what I can do.
And she dove.
She dove to 1,000 feet, and
was down for 45 minutes.
And this is her calf.
His name is Enigma,
and I surfaced.
I came up to look around.
I saw a friend of mine.
We'd just became friends.
His name is Shane Gero.
He's a sperm whale biologist who
studies the social biology
of Peruvian sperm whales.
And he just looked at me and
said, very casually, this is
the Group of Seven
you're with.
And I thought, OK, this
one whale named
Scar might be here.
And hopefully this will allow
me to make these big
photographs.
And I hadn't seen him
yet, but Scar's
younger cousin was here.
And he finally was swimming
around me.
His mother two and a half year
old cousin was in the family,
too, nursing, so he didn't
really have anything to do.
And the mothers and aunts share
the nursing duties, and
they babysit while the
mom is foraging.
So I just stayed motionless.
He swam around me.
He finally settled, probably
five feet, six feet from me,
and he gave me his right
profile, or his left profile
first, then left profile.
This is his left profile.
I hope you can see it OK.
And this was the first time that
I was able to capture,
this is probably five feet away
with an 80 millimeter
lens and a 50 megapixel
sensor.
I was starting with 50,
and I learned that 50
wasn't doing it.
But at the time it stopped
working, so I had to switch to
another lens.
And that turned out to
be the right choice.
And, yeah, I'm sorry you
can't see the detail.
It's a little too dark right,
now but I was really excited
just to see that.
And he gave me about a
half hour sitting.
And so I composed 300
photographs of his body in
sections about this wide, and I
took the 15 best photographs
and blended them together
in Photoshop, and
I'll share with you.
Let's see if this works.
Is this going to do it?
Oh, there we go.
This was the first
one I created.
I flew home within days
after this encounter.
We had to build a computer
that could complete this.
It's probably a 40 gigabyte file
with all the layers, and
I think I was using maybe 200
gigabytes of memory, which we
would use--
that we would get that from
scratch disks to handle it.
Takes like a half
hour to save.
It measures 5x20 feet.
And I just had a lot of
gratitude for this whale to
give me that opportunity.
After that happened,
I met his cousin.
I had just got on the boat,
changed my battery in my
memory card.
And I remember sitting out by
the swim step, and I just
heard my skipper say hey, look.
Look down.
This whale was coming up to the
boat, he was upside down,
which I speculate they could see
with both eyes when they
present their belly, and
gauge your distance.
And I got in the water, and
he swam right under me.
And I remember picking up my
legs, just going like this,
just to let him pass
underneath me.
And I took this photograph, and
he was preparing for his
foraging dive.
So he wasn't going to
spend very much time
with me, and he dove.
And later in the day, I
saw him one more time.
And this was my last encounter
with him, and I'll
never forget it.
It's the encounter that comes
to mind most of all when I'm
asked, what does it feel like
to swim with a whale?
Let me show you.
This is what's going on
underneath the surface.
This is all I could see.
He swam right up to me with his
lower jaw open, which can
be a threat display.
So I wasn't sure what if
he was testing me.
And his head's about this high,
and about this wide.
He's a very small whale.
He's probably 24 feet.
I'm guessing 10 tons,
maybe, or more.
If he fully matures, he
could reach 70 feet.
Historically, that's
how big they get.
And I remember feeling this dead
again as his head loomed
closer, and it finally pushed
up against my body.
And I remember putting my hand
on a whale and touching a
whale for the first time,
and pushing off.
And I remember being humbled
just by the basic observation
of his body not moving
when I push away.
And he then just heeled over 45
degrees and came forward to
meet my eye.
This is that right profile.
And as he came forward, his jaw
was still open, and it was
open underneath my body.
I was flat, and I remember
looking down, just making sure
that my feet were not going
inside his mouth.
And he has a history
of grabbing fins.
He's very tactile.
It's like an opposable
thumb for him.
It's not anything malicious,
but they will feel you.
And so I just stayed flat, and
I wondered, what's going on?
Is he testing me?
And I realized, I had
to take pictures.
So I just turned over my
complete trust to him, and
started taking pictures
of him.
The thing to think about with
this whale, when I'm asked
what it feels like to swim with
a whale, and to be this
close to a whale's eye
looking at you.
I always think of this
one encounter.
And the thing to keep in mind
with sperm whales, they're the
largest toothed predator on the
planet, and they possess
the largest brain ever
to exist on earth.
It's up to seven times
the size of our own.
They're complex social animals
who have been shaping their
culture and communication for
over five million years in
their modern form.
So if you imagine a brain that
size evolving culturally for
five million years, that's
25 times longer
than our fossil record.
Now, they're very
complex animals.
And really, the only word that
comes to mind when I
experience something like
this, the only word that
describes it is that
it's disturbing.
And it comes from the
realization of realizing we
may not be alone in
the universe.
That there's some intelligent,
conscious life in the oceans
that we can't measure yet.
And all you have is this eye
to eye exchange, and this
tangible knowing of something.
And really, that's why I
create this work, is to
inspire that next generation
of biologists, engineers.
Many disciplines, artists
who want to know.
And I don't think enough
of us want to know yet.
And with all the emerging
technologies, it's my hope
that we can at least measure and
know, because what really
concerns me most of all is the
thought of losing over five
million years of evolving
culture and communication, and
the largest brain ever to exist
on Earth, and to never
know what we lost.
And that to me is the
biggest tragedy.
Two years later, I reunited
with him.
And this kind of gives you an
idea of a typical workflow.
This is his head, this is his
blow hole, his dorsal fin.
That's my head right there.
And he gave me a four minute
sitting during this reunion,
and I composed 144 photographs
along his body.
And this is what it looks
like underwater.
This is my largest photograph.
Let's see if this works.
There it goes.
It measures 10x36 feet, has
over 20 photographs in it.
It's a 60 gigabyte file.
have to keep flattening it.
It has probably 200 layers
to it in Photoshop.
It uses probably 370 gigabytes
of memory, which I supplement
by using solid state hard
drives in RAID 0.
I'll use up to 12 of them to
act as a scratch disk.
There's his pec fin.
You can see his digits.
They have figures like
us in their pec fin.
And I haven't printed
and mounted it yet.
It will be an original
photograph.
I wanted to have the same
feeling of impermanence and
fragility that they have out
there, and I wanted to be
special for people
that see it.
Digital's exciting, but for me
it's the means, not the end.
And so I want to create some
special with digital, but not
necessarily make it
something else.
So, yeah.
Now we're getting to his tale.
When it's printed and mounted,
it'll weigh 1,200 pounds.
And that's the other reason
I haven't printed
and mounted it yet.
It needs a home.
Let's see.
During 2009, I was also
commissioned to work with the
most heavily hunted whale
in the world.
It's the minke whale.
This was on the Great Barrier
Reef in Australia.
If any of you are interested in
swimming with whales, I'm
happy to share information
with you.
But I highly recommend the
Great Barrier Reef.
There's only a five
week window.
Nobody knows why, but the
dwarf minke whales there
become incredibly inquisitive
to boats and
people in the water.
And they do come up to you.
Very close.
This is a whale I spent five
days with out of five weeks,
and as many as six
hours in a day.
Let me share some more
photos over here.
This is what's going
on under water.
This is still Ella.
She is probably three feet
away in this photograph.
I would wake up in the morning
from our anchorage.
We're probably 15 miles
offshore, and I'd pour a cup
of coffee and look out the
porthole, and her dorsal fin
would go by.
And then another one.
And at times, there would be 14
whales circling our boat in
a figure eight pattern.
And most often, Ella
would be in there.
And I'll share, hopefully these
photos will show, OK.
This will also give you
kind of an idea.
This is a portrait of Ella,
a life size portrait.
This is 4x5 feet.
But the problem is the camera
has one autofocus point, the
Hasselblad.
And so all the eyes are in the
center picture, which isn't
really ideal.
And also, that one autofocus
point focuses on particles, so
I've been eye to eye, a whale
looking at me right here, and
it's focusing on all this stuff
in the water, and the
whale's out of focus,
and I'm in tears.
But you can just add another
photograph and offset it.
And I'll show you a little
bit of detail.
Hopefully it'll show up OK, but
this gives you an idea of
just how much information
is there.
This is probably my most
detailed photograph of a
whale's eye.
That was Ella's left eye, this
is Ella's right eye.
You can see it's really
dark over here.
She's 4 feet underneath me.
I'm floating flat.
She's going like this.
That dark spot is the shadow
cast from my body.
I had to wait for her eye to
come out of my shadow to
compose that picture, and it was
like 8:00 in the morning,
so the sun was really
illuminating her eye.
Let's see if there's a little
bit more detail.
After I took this photo, I was
being transferred at sea.
I had to go to another boat,
so I had to get out.
The crew put me on a skiff.
We went to another vessel, and
I was shocked to see her and
about three other whales follow
us to the other boat.
I immediately just grabbed my
camera and went back in, and
kept photographing her.
This gives you an idea
of the workflow.
This looks a little chaotic.
There are probably 15 photograph
that I start with,
and they also look like this.
You can see all the layers
that go into, all the
adjustments or the color
adjustments, the tones.
All kinds of little photographs
that you pull in.
Some I have to create.
Sometimes I have to create water
from scratch, if I don't
photograph water by itself
after the encounter.
This is the finished
photograph.
This was at the Tamada Museum
in Tokyo in 2010.
And I'll just do a--
oh, there it goes.
OK.
This photo is 6x30 feet, and
it's my largest photo so far
that's been printed
and mounted.
There's only one company in
the United States that can
print and mount this
size in a clean
room to archival standards.
And they're in New York.
So it's a big deal every
time they're made.
You can see, like, all the
flakes of skin on her body.
These are all the subtle things
that make them real,
and that's what I explore with
my work with whales.
Bringing out every subtle detail
with them that make
them real, and really, what I
want to achieve is I want to
give you a memory of what a
whale really looks like.
Less than one millionth of 1%
of the human population will
ever be eye to eye with whales
the way I have been.
And so they're essentially
reduced to words and small
pictures, and they're not really
a part of our lives, or
they don't really move us in
ways that they have the
potential to do so.
So that's a big motivation
for my work.
So that last photo of Ella,
these last photos of Ella were
taken four weeks before
my very first
show in Oslo, Norway.
Norway's a country that
commercially hunts whales, as
well as Iceland and Japan.
And Peter had commissioned my
first exhibition there.
And the goal wasn't necessarily
to end whaling.
That takes a tremendous amount
of investment of time.
You have to be on the ground
for years, doing
all kinds of work.
Work that isn't polarizing,
though.
Sharing beautiful photos of
whales, sharing stories.
And sharing in a way that you're
allowing your viewer to
have complete freedom to explore
their own curiosity
the way I do, I do the
same with whales.
And you don't want to take that
away from anybody, even
if it's in a country
that hunts whales.
Because once you do that, you
close the door to change.
Like, you become set
in your ways.
And what was inspiring
was the response.
The show, first show was
only two days in Oslo.
We had 2,000 people show up.
Coverage on television,
newspaper, magazine, online,
and it was all positive.
And we had a completely new
dialogue about whales with the
journalists in that country.
Normally it's highly polarized
with the NGOs that I've
partnered with, and we were all
surprised that we could
have this different dialogue.
And mainly, they wanted to know
how can you get so close
to a whale without
them hurting you.
And the storytelling really
became an important part.
And the same thing held
true in Japan.
It just was really heartwarming
to know that
whales can be received this
way, and we perceive these
countries as not liking
whales, and
realizing that they do.
And it just generates so much
excitement, and it's given me
hope to draw attention to the
far more serious global scale
issues whales face.
Whaling makes up less than 1%
of what's killing them.
Commercial hunting of cetaceans,
I should say.
Whales, dolphins, porpoises.
The number one culprit is
fisheries bi-catch.
Entanglement in fishing gear,
where over 300,000 whales,
dolphins and porpoises
die every year
for our love of seafood.
And that's something I'm
exploring ways to gently
introduce into our world, and
the consequences of it.
One thing I'm working to do is
create a full body, life size
composite photo of
a living whale
entangled in fishing gear.
And that's something that,
it's a major project that
safety is paramount,
the whale's
well being is paramount.
A lot has to go into play, but
it's really my goal is to make
this a visual reality
that defies words.
My work is currently
on exhibit at
the Museum of Monterrey.
It's the first time all these
large photographs have been
exhibited together in North
America, and it'll be up until
Labor Day of this year.
And I think that covers
my introduction.
My book, "Beautiful
Whale," is here.
It just released last week.
It's my first photography book,
and I'm really excited.
I hadn't planned on doing a
book, and was encouraged to
really consider it, and
I'm grateful I did.
And I thank all of you
for coming out today.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Particularly bad
smelling minke whales?
BRYANT AUSTIN: Oh, no.
There's a story about
the name.
it was named after a Norwegian
whaler named Minke.
It was his name, and they were
hunting blue whales.
I don't know when this was.
It may have been 50 years ago,
and he said, oh, a blue whale.
And the crew found out it was
the smallest, one of the
smallest baleen whales.
And they named it--
we're gonna, you know,
name it after him.
It's a minke whale, so
I think that's how it
started, is what I'm told.
MALE SPEAKER: So obviously,
underwater photography is a
big Everest in the photography
world.
It's very difficult.
There's a lot of equipment
that's involved.
And what sort of advice do you
have for people getting
started in that medium?
BRYANT AUSTIN: I would just--
I would--
it's scary.
There's two ways you could do.
You can immediately go into a
way that's lucrative, that
produce results financially,
and you can
just create that way.
Or you can go the other way,
where you have an interest in
something, but it's not
very well defined.
And you have this thing you want
to achieve, and you just
have to be willing to
say, I don't know.
And then just go and explore.
And just decouple from the
financial pressure of trying
to make a lucrative photography
career initially,
and just create and explore.
And it's OK not to know.
And my experience in doing
that is that I've created
something way beyond
my imagination.
And that's just, yeah, that's
what I'd recommend.
MALE SPEAKER: You always see
whale watching tours when you
go to major tourist areas.
What sort of guidelines should
people be looking for in terms
of reputable companies?
Like, what should you consider
when you're going on a whale
viewing experience?
BRYANT AUSTIN: They're
so varied.
There are operators that don't
behave very well, and there
are some that are
very reputable.
It's different in other
parts of the world.
Anyone that wants to either go
whale watching, or swim with
whales, I have my business
cards here.
Just feel free to email me.
I can send you information.
There are specific companies
that I know all around the
world that are just very
respectful of whales, and the
thing that is subtle about that,
being respectful and not
chasing them, not pursuing
them, not behaving badly,
which is so common, is that
often the whales will just
come to you, and so there are
operators I can personally
recommend in at least
four countries.
So please, I'll have my contact
information here.
So, thank you again.